tôt kader abderrahim vient de nous
rejoindre le chercheur ali ps l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
spécialiste du monde arabe les de
l'islamisme les hauteurs de la
géopolitique de l'algérie aux éditions
bibliomonde bonjour merci à la lettre
pour ce plateau
la dernière information concernant la
crise en syrie réunion en urgence des
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'union européenne
pourquoi c'est là l'ouverture de la
frontière de la turquie qui inquiète la
crise migratoire 10 à 13 milles un
migrant notamment syrien bloqué à la
frontière entre la grèce et la turquie
selon un selon l'onu oui il ya une
double réseau évidemment le fait que la
turquie a décidé dorénavant de laisser
passer les migrants qui se trouvent sur
son sol
et deuxièmement l'escaladent en syrie
donc ça fait deux raisons mais je pense
que pour l'urgence pour le pour les
européens c'est évidemment de tenter de
gérer cette crise migratoire qui va
aujourd'hui devenir crucial sur sur
l'ensemble de l'europe
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre justement
de cette convocation en urgence des
mises des affaires étrangères à propos
de cette crise migratoire
il me semble que les mills affaires
étrangères vont tenter de trouver un
accord
déjà entre européens pour entamer un
véritable dialogue avec la turquie pour
tenter de faire de ramener à la raison
et en tout cas à l'accord qui avait été
signé en 2015
la turquie pour le mans d2 retenir ce
son territoire les les réfugiés qui s'y
trouve donc aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu
considérable
et puis ça a aussi une vertu en interne
à des allées garder des citoyens
européens qui doivent bien comprendre il
semble-t-il que les turcs aujourd'hui
sont ceux qui ne sont pas responsables
et par conséquent pour les européens
ils vont jouer la responsabilité de la
turquie contre le comportement de leurs
concitoyens européens pour éviter des
tensions à la fois migratoires mais
surtout politiques notamment avec les
populistes un peu partout en europe
si la turquie ouvre ses frontières c'est
pour tenter d'obtenir un appui
occidental en
en syrie ankara qui affronte damas deux
avions syriens visés par la turquie la
tension qui ne retombe pas on sait qu'il
ya eu cette semaine une réunion en
urgence au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
ait eu un échange téléphonique également
notre richie tayyip erdogan et vladimir
poutine les deux présidents qui se sont
parlés
selon même un communiqué de la
diplomatie russe
hier il y aurait eu un accord qui aurait
été trouvé entre entre moscou et ankara
cette situation semble confuse oui elle
est confuse parce que nous sommes en
train de commenter l'actualité
mais dans la coulisse il faut que les
diplomates trouvent un terrain d'entente
un compromis des convergences pour
tenter de stopper cette escalade qui est
très dangereuse qui était d'ailleurs
dangereuse pour les deux pays
parce que sur le t1 et une tragédie
humanitaire quand on vient de le voir
dans votre reportage
il ya dangereuse escalade sur le plan
militaire
évidemment qui pourrait déboucher
éventuellement sa confrontation directe
entre la turquie et la russie la russie
qui continue de soutenir le régime de
bachar al assad et la turquie qui
défendent d'autres intérêts donc il ya
une divergence importante
ankara a dit vouloir éviter toute assez
d'humour avec moscou absolument
maintenant sur le terrain on sait
absolument pas ce qui peut advenir
donc même si les militaires et les
pilotes notamment ont des consignes pour
éviter d'ouvrir le feu tout est possible
à un dérapage en tout cas est possible
donc il faut que très vite il y est un
accord un point de convergence sur cette
question là qui est très importante
parce que rappelons quand même que la
turquie est membre de l'otan membre
fondateur de l'otan et que donc il va y
avoir probablement une réunion d'urgence
de l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord qui pourrait déboucher
sur une forme de solidarité à laquelle
se doivent les autres pays de l'otan à
l'égard de la turquie ce qui pourrait
mettre là aussi une qui pourrait à
déboucher pardon sur une situation plus
confuse encore vous venez de dire il
faut trouver un terrain d'entente au
niveau des diplomates justement on sait
que emmanuel macron a appelé
la russie et la turquie l'a trouvé un
terrain d'entente mais on sait que le 5
mars normalement c'est jeudi prochain il
doit y avoir une réunion quadripartite a
priori à istanbul s'est rétracté hyper
douanes qui l'a annoncé il ya pas très
longtemps une réunion quadripartite
entre la turquie la russie la france et
l'allemagne
est-ce que ce sommet va vraiment avoir
lieu donc du coup cette semaine et
qu'est-ce qu'on pour note
en attendant ça va dépendre de la
manière dont la situation va évoluer et
pris sur le terrain en termes militaires
un set aux sangsues deuxièmement ça va
dépendre également de l'état
d'avancement des négociations entre les
diplomates concernés un russe français
allemand turc évidemment éventuellement
une partie parce qu'il faut les inclure
aussi des syriens et donc je pense que
cette l'appel des ménages macro pour
tenter de trouver un cessez-le-feu entre
turcs et les russes est extrêmement
important et probablement c'est sur
cette hypothèse en tout cas sur laquelle
travaille aujourd'hui les diplomates
dans la coulisse et ce sur quoi il vaut
il faut aller très très vite pour éviter
encore une fois une situation qui
pourrait déraper à tout moment mais
quelle marche de manoeuvre pour paris et
berlin quand on voit que le
l'aciérie ces derniers temps avait été
maîtrisé par on va dire le processus
d'astana iran russie turquie d'un autre
côté il y avait également le processus
de genève qui semblait avoir un retard
donc quelle marge de manoeuvre pour la
france et pour l'allemagne qui semble
avoir du retard quand même est-ce qu'ils
peuvent être écoutées à la fois par
vladimir poutine et parachutes tayyip
erdogan
oui je pense que quand même l'union
européenne ça continue de représenter
comme une force importante au moins sur
le plan économique
et on voit bien que les deux les deux
alliés traditionnels qu'elles sont la
france et l'allemagne les deux pivots de
la construction européenne sont
aujourd'hui à la manoeuvre
précisément et vont converger dans le
même sens pour trouver un accord et un
compromis très rapidement le procès du
d'astana de mon point de vue n'est pas
mort il doit absolument continuer de
perdurer et mais pour cela il faut
d'abord qu'il y ait entre vladimir
poutine et monsieur erdogan un accord
sur un cessez-le-feu durable et pour
éviter encore une fois les dérapages
mais la situation de faux c'est
précisément de trouver un accord sur la
question syrienne
mais aujourd'hui le président turc est
dans une phase politique où ils
déploient beaucoup d'atouts y compris on
l'a vu récemment intervenir directement
en libye après avoir signé un accord
avec le premier ministre failli à sa
rage qui se roule sur la question
énergétique de nappes gazière au large
de la méditerranée
donc ils se sont un peu pousser des
ailes et le président turc probablement
sans que il a une carte à jouer est
temps d'avancer ses pions sur le plan
diplomatique
mais là sur le terrain syrien il doit
être quand même prudent et il doit on
l'a vu et il l'a dit d'ailleurs déclaré
il veut absolument éviter la
confrontation avec la réussite ça n'est
pas son intérêt et surtout ça le
mettrait dans une très mauvaise position
vis à vis de son électorat traditionnel
merci père abderrahim c'est moi la fin
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'institut prospective de sécurité en
heure en europe spécialiste du monde
arabe et auteur de la géopolitique et de
l'algérie aux éditions imbibé
monde